citizens of the reject Nation we are
here and it is time for more Last of Us
season one episode
four episode five it's episode five I
messed you up with my bad Spanish Tara
Erickson joining me once again though
how you doing Tara hi hello I'm good as
you can see my shirt matches my
scrunchie so we could say I'm winning
winning winning
yeah winning guys subscribe to Tara's
YouTube channel she just dropped a new
short film go show that some love yeah
and as well subscribe to this YouTube
channel and when you do that ring the
bell foreign
[Music]
and also while you're ringing the bell
hit the like button don't forget to do
that and uh hey if you want to join us
for the full experience all the stuff
that gets cut out of these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com
the real reject sync up with your own
copy of The Last of Us watch long and if
you like this Nifty t-shirt that Greg
designed why don't you go check out our
merch store show your citizenship to the
nation
you know where to find that it's on
screen hey Terry you ready to go you
ready to do this I'm ready all right
thanks for keeping us uh non-spoiled us
noobs over here and uh don't forget to
check out Greg and Andrew's reaction if
you want the gamer perspective as well
Greg put us together so he deserves a
little love too and without further Ado
let's watch the shoe
[Applause]
remember how I said I wanted to go it's
the yellow fungus for Halloween
I very much remember that I said that
now I'm like I've been expecting you
know some kind of it's like a lot of
work though you know I mean I get it I
got like six months to do it but I'm
like oh this is the problem you know I'm
counting on you I know it me too nine
months down the road when it's Halloween
tell me about it I'm gonna be so early
everybody wants me to walk in as yellow
fungus because I will be the only one it
will be the coolest costume and I'm
gonna come in as butter lettuce and if
we don't match then No One's Gonna
understand John I have to do it now I
didn't know you were doing the butter
lettuce sing I'm in I'll make it happen
this is a good journey for us
oh boy ah
oh no oh civil unrest
okay
[Music]
that's hardcore
flashing back
oh my goodness what is in the actual
it's a lot more sign language in movies
and shows than ever before makes me want
to learn
good
betraying your neighbors to fedra so
that you could get medicine alcohol
for apples oh computers are fruit we
could put you on Trials you're all
guilty so that's how that'll go and
I'm easy apparently
that's Uncle Tommy's voice in the video
game this beardy guy really according to
the comments yeah that's cool
where is Henry
oh geez
I guess they don't know
oh God
uh Kelvin yeah
he had a place to hold up in the open
City
in case things went bad
things have gone great
haven't you heard okay
I want our people going door to door
until we find him door-to-door took a
lot of men in their other
s he's not my seventh priority Perry
yeah but there is something growing
through that freaking asphalt
yeah
you're gonna need men one or whatever
that is breakthrough
the fact that they did not shoot is
insane I do you all are citizens
like they would have empty
so we'll sneak our way out that'll be a
fun mission
20 cans and six pounds of jerky for the
three of us
to the minimum I think we can make it 11
days
it's not so long you have to figure it
out wow
yeah clock's ticking oh he saw a lot
that's what I can do about that now
therapy he's scared because you're
scared
this is all your fault Henry yeah man
man up
at 98 percent
[Music]
got to decorate but that kid is so cute
though
[Music]
comes crayon Oh I thought it was candy
but you know I mean I I had the beholder
you know
we all knew that kid would be candy
we got one more day of food you know
maybe they can stretch a little further
now the doctor's gone depending on where
that code decides with the timeline
yeah they're gonna start eating crayons
paint
good work
drink some turpentine they smell it to
get a little you know
going yeah take your mind off everything
and it's only been a couple minutes but
I love watching them together yeah like
all the you know
the sign language like helps with just
like emotional body language performance
yeah it's great
oh oh buddy that's so sweet what did you
guys do why are they hunting you why
were they with a doctor is the kid like
sick or is he sick and they need to
leave because they need medicine and the
cult didn't like it or maybe he's
another uh blessed child
maybe he's got the Cure oh
[Music]
that's fun
I love it
nice Super Sam cool cool detail
reflection in the night
it is the apocalypse I just want a
vanity mirror made of knives
[Music]
last time on the Last of Us
oh is this a shootout with them okay yep
semi-rashramon perspective
yeah point that thing the right
direction
remember you're training we didn't hurt
you
so you heard us that's right
so we're [__] tall man that's just
the way he sounds he has an [__]
voice Joe tell him he's okay
everything is great dude my God
see he's an [__] with feelings yeah
he's got an ass heart how old is he DJ
cool
I'm Ellie
[Laughter]
y'all came up here to get a view of the
city and plan a way out and when the
sun's up
I'll show you one through it collapsing
tunnel my help was I saw what you did
me killed those men but I don't know how
to make it through alive you seem
capable enough your arms are wrong and
wrong
I've never killed anyone and punching I
know they're gonna choose the closest
I've ever come to being bothered
oh I showed away
you clear the way
[Music]
the puns uh yes a book to good use the
great equalizer they got people posted
all around the inside Perimeter if we
get close we get caught no question
hey
let me refer to my Etch A Sketch please
oh yeah yeah yeah you notice anything
strange about this city no infected oh
infected just not on the surface that's
what we saw coming through around 15
years ago we never let them come back up
yes
it's empty
you've been down there
no
[Music]
I cleared it out all of it when three
years ago
okay maybe there's one or two will you
handle it no what if there's more or one
of those blind ones that seems like a
bat wait you ran into a clicker two of
them
clickers if it gets bad down there we
turn around and run right back all the
same way oh that's a great plan no
that's my diceyest plan but as far as I
could tell ceiling plan we got
approach
ain't nothing bad gonna happen today
[Laughter]
I like that he's honest about you know
not being 100 sure but it's also not
reassuring yeah
[Music]
Ellie Get Your Gun we're waiting for
this
she empty the plan is good dude yeah we
just got here
oh beautiful that's awesome Sam you've
been down here
is this you
know it's a rainbow room from stranger
things yeah
yeah I heard about places like this
people went underground after outbreak
day build settlements What happened to
the oh follow the rules and they all got
infected
oh I love them bonding
[Music]
four five six eleven
I love that we can complete each other's
collection and sentences
[Music]
so cool
that's great bonjour
all right endure survive [__] yeah man
each amount of say [__] yeah wouldn't be
so bad to wait light out a bit safer in
Shadows when we pop back out on the
other side Joel play date
oh my God
you know I wasn't uh
exactly telling me the truth before
oh good about me not killing someone it
was a man a great man and he's always
forgiving
he killed Jesus
Sam he uh
got sick leukemia
there was one drug that worked there
wasn't much left of it and it belonged
to fedra
of course so I gave him something big
that one Green Man the leader of the
resistance movement in Kansas City oh no
Captain's brother
oh
my goodness
you might not be her father
she was so much
[Laughter]
you waited long enough
every time someone gets close to you
Joel he's Gotta Get Away open up we
haven't found him yet
[Music]
kill Brian
he said is
long as we were together
we would be safe he was so beautiful
tell me
Michael wouldn't want me to hurt Henry
that he would want me to forgive
I know that too
but I ain't gonna do that
okay do it the last time I saw him alive
in jail
he told me to forgive
Michael sure sounds like Jesus your
brother was a great man we all loved him
hidden change anything
you did
we're with you
[Music]
yeah maybe you're the leader for the
here and now just saying I delivered
make this right go down the street
embank me behind the last house
nope here's where it all
so we crossed the river and then what
where are you gonna go I don't know yet
well we're going to Wyoming
what is a huge state it can fit two more
people
this is how it goes he's like no Ellie
never ever ever happening and then I'm
like I'm gonna ask you a million more
times
oh [__]
no no no no no no no no no
say don't talk like that we'll get 20
minutes left in the episode
actual what why
come on man
stay cool be chill I'm gonna go around
try to get in the house through the back
and then I'll take them out but if you
go out there he's gonna kill you it's
dark and he has [__] aim nobody's gonna
kill me then he's gonna kill us
you trust me
this is one of the few times the do you
trust me Trope is actually run true to
me
like by now yeah I trust you
we've we've built that trust
all right Joel this definitely feels
like a Game mission
[Music]
all right
[Laughter]
oh is it just going off and not
connected to a human yes it's like a
automated oh no it's a
okay oh hey it's the guy from The
Walking Dead season three the farm
Herschel Put the gun down
slide it over to me
and then stay up here for another hour
he's
foreign
[Music]
oh god of course
of course this is so stressful oh no oh
my God
yeah yeah yeah run run run
you're in front clear them
[Applause]
oh my God
ah
go well good job Ellie yeah yeah yeah
come on Joel
oh my goodness run left or right come on
come on come on come on exactly flank
yes that was a nice misdirect because
oh my god oh Christ this is this is so
intense
this is so bad oh gosh
go go go
yes oh thank you Henry thank God
she's chilling I'll come out
just let the kids go sorry
the girl is with the man who killed
Brian and Sam
damn you Brian I know why you did what
you did
stop to think that
think they're supposed to die he's
your kids die Henry they die all the
time wow wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
your brother was a lot older
lady what happens when you [__] with
fate uh oh oh no that's rough to hear
oh
she's just gonna do it it ends the way
it ends
of course
the ground caving in oh and they're
gonna come out now
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Laughter]
oh my gosh yeah they took us Cadets
Cadet go go go go oh my gosh that car is
not gonna protect you
nice hit y'all no no no no no it's a
clicker right
foreign
video game this and pick up some ammo
freaking
oh
wow watch where you're going buddy real
good stunts tucked in here oh yes yes
hot wire that [__] oh come on now
I'm just kidding
oh that was cool
what what
oh
[Music]
no oh goodness
supercharged oh my God he's the Hulk of
butter lettuce heads
don't look back
oh no don't sacrifice yourself beard guy
if anyone's been waiting for Carnage I
haven't I love it
[Music]
okay come on girl hit that butter
come on oh butter child
acrobatic butter child oh
oh my goodness damn it oh oh God the
contortions on this kid
damn this has to be like ripped out of a
level like you must have to cover her or
something
yes the noise the north come on
yes
yes oh oh that was so cool it's a good
thing that old dude had so many bullets
up there
oh God damn it come on come on now
ladies it's over
[Music]
here Chucky butter lettuce Chucky head
whoa
oh my God you can still spot the big in
from a mile away
oh my God that was so fun
it's enough excitement for one day
comic book say
endure and survive and dear and survive
that shit's redundant
write a comic together look I don't know
exactly how I'm getting to Wyoming I'm
probably walking
you know if you want to yeah
you have to give me a nice person to
have a friend yes please yeah
he doesn't even get out of the cars
for a second I thought terrible day up
and read
yes
pillow fight
never
never huh
[Music]
every time
it'd be crazy not to be scared
there you have it
oh
you're not alone but now we have each
other
there's a question that's a great
question
are these Romero infected or are these
some other oh no
no no damn it I knew it I knew some shoe
had a freaking drop oh
damn it
what
drink some now
oh I don't know how to feel right now
what
I'm gonna squeeze it on there whoa okay
see that's what I thought she was gonna
do for
[Music]
yeah make sure I don't turn and
12 to 24 hours or whatever the whatever
the leg diffusion time is
if he turns I'm gonna be so upset
minor tones in the end of that score
note oh
no oh this is weird fake me out please
please fake me out
damn it gosh dang it no
whoa oh my God buddy he's infected
oh
what do you do
oh God he's gonna kill himself oh no
please no
give me the gun no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
I mean
what that oh
at least he had his friend in his last
days
oh
write him a little Epitaph this is where
Ellie becomes just as broken as Joel
throws the pun book up
oh
her blood didn't work let's go
as much as you're like it can't work
that way you so desperately wanted to
yeah
right on down the road we go
oh man
wow
yeah okay I just really wanted them all
to have another adventure together I was
really excited for them to all go to
Wyoming I know right
and I and for a second there I was naive
enough to think that it could possibly
happen yeah at least for a millisecond I
was like they could then they could get
killed on the way in the next episode
exactly I'm like hey we'll have company
you know we'll get to you know Bond a
little bit more it'll hurt even worse
when we get out of the situation and
they have to die somehow but but no like
it's funny having that all happen here
was an interesting turn of events
because I feel like in a way it
spiritually counterbalances
you know the cave-in sort of saved the
day in a lot of respects and like yeah
you know they have tunnels under the
city they have moved the infected down
there at some point and then somebody
else moved them away from being you know
at least underneath the quarantine zone
so like there are things that make sense
but in that moment you're like oh thank
God you know thank God this like
Massacre took place so that we could
scrape by out of the situation but then
after that you know little boost of both
adrenaline and you know difficult
Triumph yeah there has to be sort of
like a swing back and uh and I was
they're good at making it so like you're
not even thinking about it or I wasn't
even thinking about it because in those
situations
I feel like in a show like this you have
to kind of go like okay who got bit
anytime there's a notification you got
bit someone could have got bit you know
who's not like one of our mainest
mainest characters yeah but uh yeah that
was a that was really wonderfully done I
thought in terms of how it folded out of
the previous episode and and you know
just sort of brought this situation full
circle they do a really good job of
letting us care about characters within
one episode there's not a lot of shows
that can do that
um I think it's like great writing
um yeah the whole scene was so fun I was
still like that was so fun and then I
was like now they get to just like go to
Wyoming together and then not so much
not so much yeah should have seen it
coming I didn't I was still I was still
filming pretty good getting away sure
yeah absolutely and I mean it was I
think they'd use their tones really
nicely throughout this because yeah as
like as dire as so much of this is there
are a lot of moments of levity or at
least moments of you know temporary
tenderness or Comfort or or you know
quiet that are very peaceful and Serene
and it's like even though you know it's
like they I think they did a nice job
not putting the tension where you would
necessarily expect it's like their plan
to get out of the city actually goes
down pretty smoothly yeah it's just yeah
once they get out and uh Henry
especially thinks they're safe that
everything then goes to [__]
um and yeah like I I like the just
different perspectives and yeah getting
this sort of contemplation of like hey
you know I I turned in you know the
leader of the resistance essentially to
fedra I'm like you know a fulcrum in
this conflict that also has spiraled out
into this really horrible you know
personal Vendetta with Kathleen
and you know then seeing at least a
little bit I guess
I am maybe slightly surprised given how
the show has been thus far that we
didn't dive deeper on Kathleen uh not
that we would necessarily have to
because she is
for this you know this interlude of the
plot she is the antagonist so you know
it makes more sense that we would get a
a better sense for who Henry and Sam are
it's like I get that part of this is
that you can't just you know flashback
info dump everybody because part of I
think the you know tone is about the uh
sort of fleeting qualities like you come
across people you learn a little bit
about them and they might die in this
world and you know that might be all you
get this is not like a gripe gripe but I
am like I was maybe expecting a little
more exploration of you know
what Kathleen's character is beyond just
this one yeah like you think like in
this episode that in that that little
like her pouring out her heart about a
brother was really beautiful she's in
the children's room of like having a
sentence for her saying like that's why
I ended up here do you think that I
wanted to lead like he was the leader I
was just following along I'm just like
you or something like that I mean maybe
she wasn't maybe they were just like
both leaders the whole time but it would
have been good to get sort of like a um
I don't know what do you call it like a
plot line for her like that's not that's
not the right word what is like a you
know when you're like
the pitch for her as to why she's with
the resistance but more of a a like more
of a deep felt why she's part of the
resistance not just because like fedra
sucks and they went around killing
people but like was it just because of
her brother did she want to save people
anyway I get what you're saying I feel
like they could have with a sense or two
given us more juice on her as to maybe
make us feel a little bad when she died
yes I think she was still doing the
right like being part of the resistance
but I didn't feel bad for her with what
she said at the like the end yeah yeah
and and I mean you know I'll sit here
and chew on that choice but I did think
that's where they were starting to lead
us when you have that bedroom scene and
it's like okay here we go now they're
gonna you know make me sympathize for
her and I I did in that moment I mean
like not to say that there's no Nuance
to the character because I think both in
Melanie lynskey's portrayal which I I
really liked watching her because she
has this she's just so kind of like
resign pleasantly kind of matter of fact
about everything she's just always like
you know how this is going to go yeah
I'm not gonna [__] you on anything
you know I don't even really want to be
doing this yeah and uh yeah yeah yeah so
I thought they were gonna yeah pull that
string of of making us feel that much
more conflicted or like oh man you know
I kind of
feel some kind of emotional empathy for
everybody in a very strong way and I can
see how ugly this whole situation is and
it's all there yeah but yeah I I was
maybe a little uh taken aback that you
know now now she's dead and that's
that's all we're gonna get because I
feel like you know Melanie lynskey and
and what they had going on here just it
felt like there was a lot of detail and
homework and prep that went into all
that but it kind of felt also like it
was just building like I feel like it
would have made sense if she still
survived it was like I don't know going
after him I don't know it just it was
yeah I liked the plot of that yeah yeah
and I mean on the other hand too I feel
like you know we're only five episodes
and we're still getting the sense for
how these this story moves and I think
too in in a post-walking dead world like
I feel like that would be a more Walking
Dead choice of like Kathleen scrapes by
yeah we won't see her again next episode
but sometimes she's gonna bring that
Vendetta back yeah and so here I'm like
that's not the way this world seems to
work and so in that respect like yeah
you know it's we've
not really spent more than an episode or
two on any one particular place or you
know group or anything like that so you
know it fits within the greater context
I think and and yeah I I really liked uh
just the air that permeated all of this
and and the uncomfortable but also it's
like that that tension that bubbles
underneath call moments where they're
just like isolated up in this building
looking out at the city coming up with
their plan uh and slowly you know
reluctantly opening up to the idea of
helping each other out
um and I I loved the two actors who
played Sam and Henry and I mean like
that's you know in the proportions of
everything that's I think the right way
to go is I would I definitely want more
meat on those characters you know
because they are so endearing and they
are you know sympathetic in a way that
is conflicting because you're like yeah
you did something pretty pretty harsh
and and they also you know in this fedra
versus resistance
you know conflict that is affecting
these particular characters especially
with Henry and Sam they kind of put you
on the outside of you know the real
nitty-gritty of of that so you don't
kind of get as distracted you know it's
like you can imagine you could head
Cannon out all this sort of intricacies
of the fedra versus resistance debate
but in this nutshell you're like yeah
yeah that's a a pretty desperate measure
that you took and yeah I could
absolutely see how you'd
now feel like and be viewed as the
villain because that is a pretty harsh
thing to do and it's like you had an
understandable reason trying to help
your brother and like that whole thing
of like you know look he had leukemia
and it's like you're already beating you
know the odds there yeah and then to
have it all come down to this like uh I
was just glad that I felt like Sam got
super Sam got uh Super Sam day in his
last day like to be in his footsteps
right he's been 11 days in the thing
like drawing on walls and then he gets
to sort of find a very good friend for a
while they get to play together and make
jokes like they can communicate in a
different way than he can with his
brother it gives him a little bit of
freedom because I'm sure the kid maybe
the kid didn't know but I'm sure he knew
he was sick if they if they had gotten
medicine for him right and they were
just like running out I'm sure the kid
knew like my days might be limited his
brother always seemed very honest so
um I guess in the end at least he had I
feel like a little bit of respite
because he found a really nice
friendship and I thought that was really
lovely yeah I would agree with that you
know and even though Joel and Henry
don't really you know bond that much at
least you know they they it seems like
there is a fair amount of
I don't know I think it was good for
Joel to have a guy to chat with a little
bit and to see somebody else who in a in
a way not one to one but kind of mirrors
their situation and yeah they have that
whole little discussion where Henry was
like I could tell you you know you're a
dad even if that's not your daughter
you're a dad yeah you know and and what
it means to have to look after somebody
you know under these circumstances and
and
and as much as
you know we all look to and Trust Joel I
feel like if you're with Joel you're
like okay even though things might look
dire we feel pretty safe yeah and uh and
yeah I I like the way they use that
because you know things never feel like
they're given and like watching him have
to go around the house and find the old
guy and then you know be up in the
window you know covering them with the
bolt action rifle
you know is this uh yeah I think it's
really well proportioned between things
that feel like yeah this is this is a
video game Mission and here's a big
action scene and like even the way that
yeah like this action sequence was so
you know gratifying and fun and and
crazy partly because of the amount of
restraint you know with different
episodes people have you know voiced
their uh uh you know opinions about how
long it takes to get back to infected
Mayhem and I think they also use that in
a really sort of conscientious way so
that you don't get bored of it it's not
always happening and there's always the
possibility of something like this and
then yeah here we go there's a big old
you know overflow of infected yeah and
uh what that whatever that big they
named the clicker specifically but
whatever that big dude was that comes
out and just
wrecking people yeah let us know what
those are called what was uh yeah I also
like that Sam finally
um no not Sam sorry Joel Joel had a
remember how you're saying earlier in
the episode you're like just open up
Joel I mean I feel like we're constantly
saying that about Joel but at the very
end even with Henry in that room he did
open up because it wasn't like Henry was
asking still to go with him Joel brought
it up all on his own evolution of like
if you want to come with us and I think
that was like a little side of Joel that
I don't know we need to see every so
often which we do get peeks at it of
like like I said I mean he's an [__]
with feelings and he's not really an
[__] he just like can sometimes be
he's just closed off you know yeah he's
got a huge unresolved trauma he's not
let go of enough
that's you know that's why I relate so
heavily to Joel me too uh but yeah and
and the gradual way in which we've seen
him and Ellie like I said that that
thing uh and and you know Greg and I
have joked about this before that that
you know beat of like do you trust me
yes all right we're gonna do something
crazy like so often that's a Trope that
doesn't ring and here I was like no
after seeing this journey over five
episodes I'm like I get that trust
between Joel and Ellie like that's a
great sort of illustrator of the growth
of that but also that then yeah Joel
taking that step of even though he's
initially reluctant to entertain
anything Henry and Sam have to say and I
love that that first moment of them
having the standoff and this sort of
like if we put our guns down can we just
talk about this
um and yeah and then later him you know
showing through that you know bringing
up the topic of like you guys want to
come with us you can you know like yeah
it's like he's slowly opening up to
other people as well you know especially
uh like I'm curious to to to
it's like Sam and Henry feel like you
know they've left an impact in their
memorable characters and even Kathleen
does and certainly Bill and Frank did
and I think that's interesting is like
right now any guest characters or any
sort of featured new people I'm just
gonna assume we're gonna die pretty fast
but they're good at making them feel
impactful for the time that they're here
and taking a sort of compassionate look
at who they are
um you know even if you know the the
Circ of the physical circumstances of
the situation are debatable yeah I
wonder if him meeting like Henry and Sam
is gonna
caused Joel to have like his guard down
a little bit possibly what he means I
don't think so at all I really don't
think that but like he might be a little
less resistant especially if Ellie's
like listen this doesn't not everyone is
a like a killer or infected or needs to
I don't know I don't know I just feel
like because they've had
a good like not a good experience but
like an okay experience with someone
they ran into and strangers that
um I don't think he'll let his guard
down but you never know he might be more
like welcoming to strangers when they
pop up again the idea of people's
Humanity seems to be a little closer to
home for him yeah than it did in the
first episode or the first couple
episodes yeah and two I mean I'm curious
to see how they continue to explore the
idea of of just what this world makes of
people I've seen you know slight
discussions about how you know uh people
portray like when
resistances to oppressive power go too
far themselves and what that means is a
story Message and and certainly here
it's like you know you have this
resistance in what Kathleen is doing
that does seem like it's turned into a
tyrannical problem of its own which
isn't like however resistance is but I
feel like you know you can see also
probably that'll be explored if and when
they meet back up with Tommy and you can
see like there's versions of succumbing
to the muck of your circumstances that
have already been touched upon you know
they've they've had Joel and Ellie even
have to talk about you know like you
know have you done have you killed
people before like they run into that
guy uh last episode with the whole ruse
about like help I'm injured and then
they get ambushed and it's like you can
tell it Joel and Tess have probably done
something like that in the past or
whatever and so I think those are
interesting conversations to have and
I'm curious to see how the show
continues having them
um because yeah this is the world
they've drawn is is nice and uh and as
much as I wanted the blood cure to work
I think that was
yeah I'm like it's too easy because then
if Joel gets bit we don't have to be
worried she just slap some blood on
there yeah yeah and they yeah and going
back to the beginning it's like that
allows
Sam to have his final moments be
peaceful and you know he's probably
comforted in the idea that he's going to
be fine and yeah you know and then he
eventually turns
ah little dude I know I really liked the
both of them I'm gonna I'm sad that
they're gone
I'm glad that we're out of that City but
I'm sad that they are gone and uh yeah
you got any more stray thoughts or ideas
before we hit the road on this one and I
just wonder if we'll meet more
resistance uh groups along the way I'm
sure we will which I think I mean maybe
not but if there's ephedra in every city
right yeah yeah yeah it's like we've got
to meet like a quirky fedra camp that
doesn't do things the normal thing yeah
who's like doing fine until some like
random ass thing goes down and then they
all get wiped out and there will be like
you know a hippie commune yeah where
everybody loves them they don't have any
resistance there because we're all one
big family yeah yeah yeah there will be
like a super religious cult it's like
you know holding up in fact kind of like
that one walking deadline where they got
all the uh zombies in the barn and
they're like no no we could cure them
yeah there'll be that I'm sure at some
point but in a church yeah yeah they've
got all these infected just changes
they're like we've been spraying holy
water on them all night so hard and we
all the kids are a little too little for
this uh well hey thanks for joining me
this is a blast as well and uh hey if
there's anything we missed or any trivia
any pertinent little game-oriented
details about this episode leave them
below no spoilers please uh you know if
you got to this point and it's still not
clear we are noobs we haven't played
stuff and you guys have been so lovely
about keeping our uh you know our
experience fresh and untainted with
spoilers so uh thank you guys leave a
like subscribe and last but not least
let's do a little patron of the day
shout out yeah yeah
Tyler Hague Tyler my dude if there's
anybody I would want with us you know if
we if the grid went down and there was
some kind of big infection outbreak I
will watch you on the team I want you on
the squad because think of it you are a
good-natured person I don't think you
would lose your Humanity in the
apocalypse every time we've ever spoken
I feel just like better about life in
general you got a soft disposition but
you're also a formidable guy you know if
we got into some [__] out there you
could probably knock over a few infected
just with your bare hands you know and
that's the good you know you're you're
the the I feel like you're probably
pretty tall you come across as a tall
guy and in that regard I would say you
might be sort of a gentle giant for our
resistance party heck yeah all right and
uh yeah we just love you here at the
reject Nation if you ever get bit or
anything like that we will do everything
we can you know we'll cut off an arm you
know whatever it takes you know and for
sure and if you did you know get fully
infected I think all of us would just
choose not to go on because you're just
that good of a guy and it wouldn't be
worth it in the apocalypse without you
it wouldn't be worth it Tyler so uh be
well stay well stay pledged and we'll
catch you next month love you buddy